hello and welcome to the evan carmichael
show i believe in entrepreneurs i want
to see you achieve massive success with
your company
and i get frustrated when entrepreneurs
are struggling and you're not getting
the momentum you need with your company
you're not getting any forward movement
it's taking longer than you thought it
would be you know you're all alone and
you're struggling and i'm not talking
about the entrepreneurs who
are just trying to rip people off we're
just trying to scan people out of money
you know these are people like you who
are trying to do something good you have
a good product you have a good service
you have noble intentions you want to
change the world for the better and it's
still
hard and you're still struggling and you
feel all alone that's why i'm here to
help that's what this show is all about
and i think you're going to like it
today on the agenda
how to be great
how to start a business with zero
experience how to get massive traffic on
a limited budget and the best way to
grow your business
be great
earlier this week i threw out months of
work
that myself and my team have been
working on and this was work that we
were really proud of this was work that
was cutting edge in our industry this is
work that we threw away before it really
even had an impact we launched it softly
and people loved it and i'm deciding to
throw it all away and before you think
evan
maybe you need to calm down a bit maybe
you should go see a doctor chill out a
little bit and think about this
the reason why i'm doing it
is become i came up with something great
i came up with something even better
than what we were doing
and this is the challenge because for
entrepreneurs you have to do great work
if you want people to talk about you if
you want word of mouth marketing to
spread for you you have to do something
great
people don't talk about ordinary
products and ordinary companies you have
to push the boundaries and challenge
yourself to do something great and doing
something great is scary
because it often means
doing something you've never done before
i'm challenging my team to do something
that they have never done before nobody
has done this before
and this is the goal that we're
attacking
and they'd love it
because they want to be a part of a
great company they want to be part of a
company that's doing great things
if you want to attract customers if you
want to attract good employees if you
want to attract media and investors you
have to be doing something great
remember that good is the enemy of great
oftentimes what we do as entrepreneurs
is we settle we settle for good enough
we say ah that's good enough
and we put it out
and that attitude is gonna kill your
business
if something is bad you're going to fix
it
but if something is good enough
you're probably not going to do anything
else with it
you're never going to be great because
you're settling for good enough and
people don't buy some good enough
companies people don't buy good enough
products people don't like working with
a good enough team
you have to challenge yourself to
constantly think about how to be great
stop settling for less
and this is something that applies not
just to your business this isn't just a
business principle this is for your life
you want to just be good enough in your
life do you want a good enough life you
want a good enough relationship
or do you want a great life
and a great relationship
every major breakthrough that happens in
your business or your life will come
when you increase your standards
you raise your standards you raise what
you will no longer accept
you don't accept mediocre work anymore
you don't accept a bunch of mediocre
products
and when you do that you'll start to
transform yourself pick one thing your
homework for today is to think about
just one thing in your business that is
good enough you said to yourself in the
last week that's good enough one thing
and make it great
and as soon as you start making one
thing great
you change
and you want to make other things in
your business great and other things in
your life great it's your challenge for
the week
one thing that is good enough in your
business make it great and you'll start
to transform yourself and your business
and you'll start seeing amazing results
i want to get to the call i have matt on
the line matt how can i help
hi my name is will i am 26 years old and
i'm trying to start my own custom
skateboard design company
and what i wanted to know is how could i
you know trademark my brand because i
just wanted to know what's the fastest
way to get this brand some exposure
what got you in the skateboard and i
love skateboarding i'm on uh i just got
a ripstick earlier this year have you
heard of that
um actually i have it's really cool
do you have one
um no actually a friend of mine does
basically
what got me into skateboarding really is
actually when i was a kid i played tony
hawk's underground skateboarding for the
playstation actually and it really got
me hooked into this into this world of
skateboarding so the video game god
should want to make a company
yes yes it's it's crazy but it'll happen
because when i see people and i see them
writing and i realize it's a way to
express yourself you know it's a way so
i would love to be able to just make you
know to customize um these logos and
things like that because
you can express yourself through your
board
so what's so special about what you're
doing here
well personally i think it's special
because um
specifically with
i i really like expressing yourself in
many different ways you know with in in
anything so i feel as if i would
specifically be you know be helping kids
or or um people
just be able to express themselves
through their boards now are you is it a
custom board is it custom artwork for
the board what are you starting sorry
yes there's a custom artwork sorry yes
custom artwork okay yes and it fits on
any board
yes what's the funkiest one that you've
done so far i would i would have to say
um
what people what people think of is
mostly uh comic book characters or
things like that but trying to you know
make them really just
very look very out there
very very you know different very uh
unique so maybe it'd be instead of black
and white it's black and white it would
be a well actually would be black and
white more like a noir kind of setting
let's say for batman or something along
those lines
okay
what's your biggest challenge right now
with it
the biggest challenge is really just i
mean getting out there because you know
you have you'll have some people who who
uh you know are interested but it's
really hard to just branch out and to
kind of
uh you know get get my company known
so
are you talking to the actual skateboard
owners are you going to the
manufacturers the retail stores or who
are you targeting here i'm i'm trying to
target owners specifically because i
feel this you know i mean
i think with what we do here would be
best to target specific people but i'm
really asking you what do you think
would be best to
really kind of go after because i
it's you're struggling to get it going
yeah yeah pretty much it's i don't know
your pain okay yeah i mean i'm gonna
talk about later in the show but one of
the fastest ways to grow a business is
through partnership especially when
you're first getting started
because going after one customer at a
time at a time at a time can be really
hard and time consuming
and hard to make a buck
so i'd be looking at who already owns my
target audience the kids who are buying
skateboards yes who's already selling to
them and how can i make some kind of
partnership right
so if it's a retail store or a website
or
whoever it is like who can you think of
who's already selling skateboards to
these kids is there somebody local you
can think of right away like where did
you buy your skateboard oh it's actually
uh it's been a while the place actually
closed down it was a local kind of place
and it's about but no but you're right i
should definitely target more towards
these stores and i'll have to look more
into the area it's just it's been hard
you know when you have to juggle real
life and then this business on the side
it's true
and you know what what you said was
really important that board company that
you bought yours from they shut down
yeah because they have they have nothing
to separate themselves from every other
skateboard shop right
so this could be an opportunity for them
to stand out to be different
yes an opportunity to make more money
and also for you to promote your
business
i wonder if there's something too that
you can use something fun something to
help you get in the media what could you
do that's fun that's timely that
somebody might put on their board that
kind of relates to a trend that's
happening right now
it's funny i think i would have to if i
could really think i would think maybe
trying to do celebrities or like maybe
funny celebrity heads or something like
that i know miley cyrus is in the media
maybe you partner up with one of those
uh those street artists who do
caricatures actually yes yes that's
actually oh that's actually a really
great idea
a little surprise but i know i'm just
kidding but i know it's i know it's very
interesting actually i that's what
popped it in my head that kind of design
so it actually and you know it would be
great to just
uh get someone involved like that
all right and i'm sure they're looking
for more exposure too so it's another
type of partnership right you're
partnering up with
somebody who has this great artistic
talent
and popping out on your board yes so
it's stopped trying to do everything
yourself stop trying to get every
customer yourself start coming up with
every design yourself and partner up
with people who have this expertise
right so the stores we need a way to
stand out
the artists on the streets you need a
way to make more money like this could
be great opportunities for you to think
about what do you do best in the world
and how can you partner up with other
people
do the rest okay
does that make sense yes it does all
right good luck keep me posted i want to
hear about your progress all right thank
you so much no problem all right bye-bye
for everybody listening and if you're
like matt you know if you're struggling
to do everything yourself you gotta
realize this is a tough thing to do you
can't do it alone
you have to bring on people to help you
or partners to help get you where you
need to go i got a question recently
from a youtube viewer who wrote in to
say i have a huge passion for my
business but i have no experience and no
capital how do i start a business with
no experience
here's the thing here's here's an
important rule in business to remember a
lot of it will boil down to this if you
want to make money you have to be able
to provide value to your customers okay
you want to make a lot of money you have
to be able to provide a lot of value you
want to make a lot of money quickly
provide a lot of value quickly
usually
you get value by having some kind of
experience right how can you provide
tons of value to your clients if you've
never done it before and you have no
experience
so my advice typically for entrepreneurs
here is go get a job
what
mr entrepreneur is telling me to go get
a job
yes because if you just start a business
and you have zero experience you're
gonna crash and burn you don't know what
you're doing and you have no background
to help your customers
but if you get a job working for a
company who can train you to be a better
entrepreneur who can train you to learn
about your industry who can train you
so that when you get started
you're rocking and rolling you hit the
ground running you have the contact and
experience and money to launch this
thing that's the best way to do when i'm
starting a a new venture if you're
getting into something
the only point of getting the job is not
to make money you're not getting the job
to make money you're getting the job to
get paid
to learn you're going to university
getting paid to do it
at the same time start up your business
on the side
to build some experience and that might
mean taking on clients for free that
might mean taking on clients or cost or
a tiny profit you're just building up
your experience in your portfolio and
you're learning how to add value and
when you know you're adding lots of
value to your customers you can start
charging more and more and more and
eventually break out from your job
and do your business full-time that's
how you get started
you have to try to find ways to add
value and the easiest way to learn about
the business is to go work in it for a
little bit don't have some job that
you're not learning anything
work to learn invest that back into
yourself and never go into your business
and help you launch a successful
business i want to get to the call i
have michael on the line michael where
are you from and how can i help
well i'm from utah but i live in new
york
new york all right what's up
uh well listen i'm i'm retiring and um i
have an idea for a product
but i'm not interested in in being the
spokesperson i'm interested in just
making the new product and then
licensing it
to somebody else to do
so i'm not sure how to protect myself
and to uh do i need to do a schematic do
i need a copyright what do i need to do
to protect myself
why don't you want to be the
spokesperson
well because i just don't have the
energy to um to go out and do the sales
and all that stuff that's required you
know i watch some programs and i i know
that there are some saying hey look i'll
i'll take your idea and we're gonna do
that and we'll give you a cut of
whatever we make you've been watching
sharks tank
i have been all right
all right it's a good show two of them
are canadians too i'm from i'm from
canada so no i won't do that again
uh tell me what your product does for
your invention
well um basically what i've taken the
concept i'm a singer and i've taken the
i believe that that singing like
bodybuilding you have to exercise it
every day and you have to do certain
things i come from a foundation of
technique that's kind of spread around
the country and i'm trying to
consolidate it into an online studio
but one of the issues especially in new
york city is that how do you practice
without annoying your neighbors to hell
so my idea is to i have a concept for an
uh an item that would allow you to sing
and yet not have your neighbors here
so i call it
closer
does it work is it proven or is this an
idea
well it's proven in its um organic form
okay it don't make any sense
okay
it works in your apartment
oh yeah oh yeah yeah i used it for years
okay i could talk to neighbors and they
won't say this guy is yelling at the top
of his life
absolutely
all right
so okay here's the thing finding a
partner finding somebody to work with is
hard right it's like getting married
it's not just oh i'm gonna post an ad
somewhere and somebody's going to be my
partner
and if you make the wrong decision here
you connect with the wrong person it
could sync your business you don't want
to get in bed with the wrong guy the
best way for you to find the right
person is ideally you find somebody who
is also passionate about singing and
about bringing new products to market
but has
the marketing expertise
right they love saying they love this
idea
by the way they don't know how to create
a product but their expertise is in the
marketing side
right to find this person
do i write a schematic or do i draw do a
little drawing well this is where i'm
lost
okay but the draw is not going to do
much for you you have to get somebody to
see it and to witness it right you have
to get if it's working in your apartment
you're going to have to get them into
your apartment so they can see it
right they can go to like your next-door
neighbor or stand outside the the
hallway
and you're sitting at the top of your
lungs and they can't hear anything
right
i'm not concerned about that at this
point i'm concerned about protecting the
idea
and to to to making whatever i need to
do particularly
with with music original music a basic
way of protecting yourself is to email
yourself a registered letter or send
yourself a registered letter with the
content and not open it
but i'm not sure about this kind of
thing if i draw out what it is and do a
detail of what the product is how do i
protect myself have you started selling
it yet
well no i'm just i it's it's it's
basically i've been using it myself and
i want to protect the idea
okay so if you haven't started selling
it yet you can create a patent
and your
the start point is called the
provisional patent and that gives you
international protection you can do it
for a year with the potential to expand
and that gives you coverage in in the
u.s canada everywhere
after
a year plus potentially more if you
renew then you have to go for full-blown
patents and that that you have to do in
each country
you got to think where do i want this to
be protected because you got to pay
every year for each country to keep that
patent alive
but what it does is give entrepreneurs
the provisional patent gives
entrepreneurs a way to protect their
idea for a short amount of time
to see if they can commercialize it
right
right so your best friend is to you you
will have to detail everything
that goes into making that product
amazing
and talk to a lawyer to draft a
provisional patent
okay so i need a lawyer to draft a
patent there's not something i can do
myself
it's not something that you want to do
yourself now you can do a lot of the
background work because lawyers they
charge you for every hour right
yeah i charge you for every hour deal
with lawyers yeah you want to limit your
time but if you can do all the
background work as much as possible
then then they're they're there to do
what they're really good at and create a
natural pattern
okay
okay good luck michael keep me posted
i sure will thank you evan all right no
problem cheers very interesting call i
love hearing about new inventors and
what they're all about i got a great
question from one of my youtube viewers
earlier this week his name was robert
and he is an affiliate marketer and he's
trying to figure out how do i get
massive traffic to my website on a
limited budget
so here's the thing
okay if you are paying people to come to
your website you're never going to have
huge success because you're always
paying for it
you can't be paying per click you can't
be paying for advertising because it's
not going to have a huge impact on your
site we're talking about a limited
budget right we have limited budgets as
entrepreneurs
so you're not going to get huge amounts
of traffic if you have to click each
time because you're limited in how much
money you have
but here's the thing
people love sharing content
online
but to make it work it has to be great
back to our first topic of the day it
has to be great
what do you have inside you that you
want to share with the world what is
wrong with what's happening right now
what are the major pains that you're
solving for your customers
and create content that speaks to it
think about your own experience online
okay i know you spend a lot of time
online i know you check out a lot of
websites
what do you spend time on what do you
pass on to your friends
is it gonna be content that's just okay
that's just kind of throwing up there
something it might just be for search
engine optimization reasons do you share
that kind of stuff
no
you share the meaningful stuff or the
fun stuff you share something that's
gonna have an impact
so you need to be that person creating
the content you need to have something
that you're creating that people will
want to share
you need to create something that is
remarkable think about that word
remarkable it means make a remark about
is what you're doing
remarkable is what you're creating worth
making a remark about if somebody visits
your website is there anything on there
that is worth making a remark about
probably not
so that's the challenge
but it's within you to create something
amazing and your homework is to sit down
close your eyes and think about
one major pain that you help your
clients with what is it that you help
your clients what they love coming to
you for this reason
what is it what can you solve and then
explain in detail how to do it
give them tons of value
have a passionate plea throw yourself
into this content
and if you're writing a blog post if
you're creating a video if you're
tricking it down into a series of tweets
whatever it is whatever your medium is
you're most comfortable with
it has to be meaningful it has to be
valuable it has to make people take
notice
and want to change their life somehow
it's got to be that important if it's
not that important people won't share it
and it doesn't matter how big a budget
you have people are not going to come
and visit your website and stick and buy
stuff from you
a big problem with uh robert here is
that is an affiliate market a big
problem with affiliate marketers
typically is they sign up for
whatever affiliate marketing program and
they don't believe in it they sign up
just trying to make a lot of money
somebody's promised them hey here's a
great way to make a lot of cash quickly
that's not the reason to start a
business
if you have never used the product or
service that you're selling you're not
going to be successful
a lot of these affiliate marketers they
just take whatever website is given to
them and then they're told if you can
drive a thousand people to this website
we're gonna convert x percent you're
gonna make tons of money
nobody's gonna go to that website
because there's nothing there it's just
a sales page are you gonna promote a
sales page to your friends and family
no
you have to tell a story you have to
make it personal you have to share
a huge pain point that people are facing
how to overcome it
it's more rewarding for you and it draws
people in and makes them want to share
so think about one major thing that you
can create great content on and put that
up
and watch it grow and watch people come
to your website
believe
i want to get to the call i have chris
on the line chris where are you from and
how can i help
i'm in north carolina north carolina all
right what's going on
yeah um just uh
i i have something amazing just i have a
form of aerobics that i teach and um
what are you teaching
i teach a formal arousal that i created
myself in patent um but i'm trying to
get my product out there you know more
in the public eye you know uh but my
thing is i was i'm i'm limited limited
funds too as well but i'm trying to get
a sponsor that i'm trying to find out
what direction i need to go into to get
a sponsorship
or
which which kind of team should i work
with uh should i be pushing for like
under armour or should i be pushing for
uh like beachbody
that was my question
so what do you learn in this course
uh what what i do in in
i didn't hear you
what do you learn so by by buying your
product what am i going to learn what am
i going to get better at
first and foremost you get you get
healthier
uh if you lose weight or you get in
shape or you get more muscle ability
more muscle agility uh the things that
the product brings is fun exciting uh
it's not just your regular aerobic uh
one two three four five six it has a
format it's fine uh the energy level and
you know it's just more or less
just a different variety you you have
cars but you have
uh you have lexuses you have uh ferraris
this is a ferrari it's not a hugo
okay so you gotta tell me what's
different so it's uh the difference is
same thing
well
with march aerobics it's called march
robes i i created it in um
from hbcu style marching bands in
traditional bands like ohio state like
notre dame uh michigan and all the
and the movements that we do are high
stepping movements the uh high knee lift
and them and the gestures and the dances
and the moves and that energy is is sort
of like promulgated into the aerobics
and just like you have taebo the basis
of taibo is uh martial arts where the
basis of mine is marching band and it's
fun it burns 800 to a thousand calories
i'm just really trying to get
sponsorship i'm really you know i've
been doing this for 13 years and it's i
know it's time for me to really make it
to the top
and i and when i say the top i strive to
be an international fitness icon
and you know i that that's that's just
my goal
how have you done so far how are you
doing right now with the business you've
done this for 13 years half hour
i'm okay you know i'm all right i'm all
right but
not on the level that i know i can be on
you know i just moved to charlotte from
mississippi which is the number one
obese state in america
and um i just moved here and i'm you
know um just really trying to get my
name out here in the city and and around
in the areas i've done some expos i've
done some big things but
not like i say not on the level that i
strive to be on
you've got to do something to create
noise you've got to do something that
builds momentum that people will stand
up to pay attention to so that's why
under armors of the world come to you
right if you're going out to them and
saying hey i have a fitness product
these guys are getting pitched all the
time
and i need you to start to create
right like i've never heard of this
this uh this form of fitness i didn't
even understand it when you when you
said the word at the start of the topic
but that's okay like now
that's what you do
right so how can you get a million
people on one youtube video to watch
something that you're doing can you work
with the band can you work with the
schools can you what can you do to get
something going to build some momentum
around this you know and i work with the
bands i work with a lot of bands i
actually um i'm a clinician too i'm i'm
a i'm a former drum major at uh jackson
state and uh so you're putting up on
youtube are you putting up on facebook
and twitter and asking the students to
share it
yeah you can i have i have videos and
stuff like that but the thing is how do
you how do you really get it to go viral
i mean i i i i i usually don't utilize
it on facebook you know twitter of
course but you know just to actually
make it go viral i i i haven't gotten to
that level yet and actually i mean you
know homework here's your homework this
is it here's your answer okay
okay this this is it
you gotta talk to the bands and have
them come up with
something amazing like what's the most
spectacular trick something that you can
tie into your workout regime but
something that people love watching this
stuff there's whole competitions around
it something that is going to drive
people
to go crazy watching it and then get the
students involved in helping promote
this thing because it's the young people
who have all the connections online
especially
put into your twitter account you got to
get them to say look what we just
created that was right
so i need to be attracting uh
the youth and and and um but you have to
make something the video has to be great
so video promotion has to be something
that people haven't seen before
challenge the band come up with
something that people haven't seen
before i haven't you just gave me a
great idea and i appreciate it you
really did nobody
i'm feeling it i'm feeling it tell me
how it goes in the two weeks when i'm
back on okay all right man thank you
thanks so much
i got a question from one of my readers
about how do i grow my business what's
the best way to do it so he's uh he's an
insurance company his name is he sells
insurance and he's been doing this for
18 months he's all alone
and he's cold calling he's had he's
having little to no success
i can get in the whole thing about cold
calling it may work for some people i'm
not a huge believer in it you're
interrupting people in their day
and it's getting harder and harder to
reach people on the phone
but the best way to build your business
this is what we're talking about with
will from the top and our skateboard
designer is partnerships
find someone who's already fell into
your target market and find a way to
work together somehow
it's the easiest way to grow a business
because instead of selling to one person
at a time at a time at a time you're
selling someone who can pass you a
stream of ongoing business
so let's talk about insurance for a
minute i just got a
a new apartment okay so the question is
moses is an insurance guy how do i make
partnerships so i got my apartment i'm
working with a real estate agent who i
love his name is mark
and mark tells me upon closing that i
need to get
insurance so i say mark where do i go
for i said well where do you bank i said
td let's go talk to td
this was an opportunity for mark to
stand out and tell me hey here's moses
or here's whoever i recommend to be a
great insurance agent
by doing that it's great for moses it
gives him a new customer it's great for
me because it solves a problem for me
and it's great for mark
because now
i look at him as an even better contact
i'm so happy i'm probably going to refer
him more business to help everybody just
got to reach out to those connectors
who already have your target market and
you can provide a value-add service to
their clients i have nerman on the line
nerman where are you from and how can i
help
hi evan i'm calling from new york new
york i've got a lot of new yorkers today
uh it must be your lucky day but
i've got a question about the business
that i just launched
about two weeks ago i launched a social
networking website which is for women
who are interested in finding and
meeting new friends
the website works in two ways it matches
you to other girls who are very similar
to you so
they're in your age range um they have
you know a relationship they have
children whatever um once you're matched
to those girls you get like a percentage
rating on your friendship compatibility
and then you can directly reach out to
those girls to arrange for coffee or to
get dinner or whatever um harmony for
women
for friendship
yes what's the name of your website
it's called
l-u-m-e-l-l-e
l-u-m-e okay
okay what what made you want to start
this thing
um it's actually based heavily on my own
personal experience i've been living in
new york city for about three years
and i came in with high hopes thinking i
was going to have a million friends and
it was going to be so easy and we were
going to go out to bunch and dancing and
yada yada ya but after two years of
living here i realized that i only had
two really close girlfriends but several
acquaintances but no one i could feel
comfortable enough to call and say hey
let's go out for a drink tonight let's
go get brunch um
so what's the main problem now how to
get exposure for this
yes how do i get exposure for this and
how do i sort of connect to the female
oriented brand to
sort of want to partner with me to do
events together like
you know whether it's lululemon or you
know bobby brown makeup or whatever it
is how do i sort of get them to see that
you know i have a value that i can add
which is bringing in you know women
buyers you know for whatever product
that they're selling but my producer is
in my ear fernando who's a woman and
she's writing this is a great idea
that's so wonderful tell her to join
okay
nobody's talking about this there's a
lot of stuff about dating advice but
there's nothing talking about how to
build friendships
yeah what i would do is try to create
a media stormer on this like this is
something that should be able to be
picked up by major media outlets right
what is it
that is so important about this and you
could tell your story i think this is a
great example where there's you know
girl moves in new york wants to make
friends biggest city in the world should
be tons of people and
and yet she has two good friends
right like we're still connected and yet
we're so far apart
yeah it's a great story and it's
something that nobody's talking about
and and i see this as
something that the media would pick up
maybe you get a regular advice column
just as it would be for a relationship
column and giving advice
for women on
on how to make friends and the website
could be obviously a big part of it but
what else can you do and after you you
know meet them for coffee or whatever
happens on your first
meeting giving people advice and what to
do and you could be the the nationwide
expert on this
on how to make friends and how to keep
them
for women right for sure yeah i think
guys would interact in a different way i
don't i don't know if guys would go
online and try to find the new bff the
website
um but but girls like women i could see
it happening for
yeah exactly and and what's interesting
is everyone that i've talked to has had
through the same response which is it's
really hard to find friends after
college
for some reason that seems to be the
point where everyone just sort of
becomes very distant and it becomes
difficult for women
do you have any connections in the media
or any thoughts of how you can start
this thing in the media
no um i did hire uh some of the last
pennies i have left for this investment
i did hire a pr firm to sort of help um
but you know pretty pretty uh useless
right
um
uh maybe a little bit i mean we won't
get into it all right you know what you
can do your own pr and reporters are
super easy to get in touch with because
all of their email addresses are
typically available on their websites
yeah when i first started my business
that's what i did i did a new press
release every week
to my audience and it was it wasn't just
your typical press release hey new
website but it was
something that told a story that had an
impact
and every week i got picked up by
somebody else either tv or radio or
newspapers and they wanted to interview
me
that got that's got to be you and you
can do it by building your own list
find out anybody who talks about
relationships or women's living women's
lifestyle that kind of stuff
build a list and every week or every two
weeks send them a new idea
with facts and with the story and
something that has a personal connection
but they'll want to interview you and
run with it
okay that's a great idea thank you i'm
excited and keep me posted if if you
don't my producer is going to get upset
at me so
okay thank you all right oh she's asking
me again what's the website again it was
it was lou mal right
yes i'll use it one more time for
everybody e-l-l-e all right thank you
and good luck
thank you no problem thank you everybody
for joining i hope you had a great time
i want to thank my producers fernanda
and kevin first time on the show kevin
welcome aboard
nan is now a guest star popping into my
ear
i'm on every two weeks i will see you in
two weeks keep believing keep moving
forward on your goals i will see you
soon thank you guys take care
you